all right welcome to the live stream a
lot to talk about today we are going to
talk about taxes in a bunch of different
ways I may open up the phone lines and
take calls from the audience we will see
about that what else I don't know people
have questions we will talk about them
super chat is available I guess I'll go
through that right off the top this is a
live stream this differs from the videos
that I upload to YouTube and that this
is live unless you're watching the
replay best ungrate is to send a super
chat use the dollar sign at the bottom
of the chat window you will notice in
the chat window by the way that channel
subscribers have little logos next to
their name and all sorts of different
stuff goes on in the chat sign up for
membership there's some coupon codes in
the description to get a live thank you
during the stream if you do that and we
get ten people to do that I will open up
the phone lines please don't troll the
live chat we do have today I've put the
live chat over here and that may be
extraordinarily short-lived depends I
guess on what happens with it it can get
pretty bad in the chat so that'll stay
up for a little bit and if it gets bad
then I will take it away and you can
also become a YouTube channel member
with the join button if and when you do
that you will notice that it conveys all
sorts of different benefits to people
including that when you say something in
the chat over here there will be a
variety of little icons that pop up next
to your name people already saying it's
not going to take long before I pulled
the chat off of the screen and you are
probably right you are probably right
okay so we're going to talk about taxes
today in a few different contexts
there's sort of two main discussions
surrounding taxation that are relevant
right now since it is getting to be tax
time and it's tax time for the first
time since the Donald Trump Republican
tax reform which was billed as a tax cut
for everybody it's a tax cut mostly for
rich people with some small changes for
everyday Americans and we're going to
get into sort of two different elements
element one is what tax policy is best
for the country in terms of the revenue
that it provides to the government to do
things now if you don't believe that
it's good for the government to have
money with which to do things then
you're going to have a sort of different
perspective on this issue but the first
question I'm going to address briefly is
what level of Taxation brings in the
most money for the government then we're
going to get into what is the effect
that the micro-level on people of the
tax plan that was passed and
unfortunately both cognitive dissonance
and ignorance are preventing a lot of
people from actually understanding what
the true and real impact is on them so
first let's address the issue of
taxation at the the sort of country
level there are a few different
approaches to taxation one more often
called supply-side economics is that if
you cut taxes for the rich and for
corporations this will give them more
money with which they will then do
things that are good for the economy and
usually the talking points go if you cut
taxes for the rich they're the job
creators so they will create more jobs
or if you cut taxes for corporations
they will pour that money back into
hiring more people this doesn't actually
make any sense okay and a very simple
counter example explains to us why that
is if you are a business that sells I
don't know you sell mobile phones for
example if the demand is for 100 mobile
phones per month and all of a sudden you
as a business get a tax cut why would
you go and hire more people if the
demand for your phone is still 100
phones per month that's what we would
call stupid you would go and hire more
people if all of a sudden the economy is
demanding 200 phones per month now you
need to
manufacture an additional hundred phones
and thus you need the people to do that
so when demand for your product goes up
you would hire more people if you're a
business and you get a tax cut that's
not a reason to go and hire more people
it would be stupid to do that because
the number of people you need is
determined by the amount of demand for
your product or service so that is not a
good approach to figuring out what sort
of national taxation is best for
government revenue Donald Trump said
those tax cuts will grow the economy so
much that then tax revenue will go up
because all these people will be earning
income and there will be new income tax
it just hasn't happened ok so what we
know when we look at the science of it
and this includes considerations like
what mit has done in looking at where
should the top marginal tax rate be
placed and a lot of other studies what
we get to to sort of cut to the chase is
that a top marginal tax rate somewhere
between 70 and 75 percent is what
maximizes government revenue now does
that mean that I'm talking about a 70
percent total tax rate that you just get
seventy percent of your money collected
in taxes no we're talking about a 70
percent marginal tax rate that marginal
tax rate would start depending on which
idea you look at at high incomes incomes
of seven hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year a million dollars a year
under some plans even five or ten
million dollars a year so only on
earnings above that point would anyone
pay that top marginal tax rate that is
what generates the most revenue for the
government at the macroeconomic level
let's now get into the meat of what's
being discussed now as people are
starting to file their 2018 taxes and
we're getting closer and closer to tax
day which is normally April 15th unless
April 15th falls on a weekend which it
may this year I don't know in which case
it gets pushed a day or two there are
more and more Americans including
Trumpets who are complaining that they
are getting much smaller tax refunds
than
last year now this doesn't actually tell
us whether people are paying more or
less in taxes okay and this is where a
combination of cognitive dissonance in
some people who really are paying more
in taxes but they don't necessarily want
to accept it because they voted for
their orange lord and savior donald
trump and then now their taxes what went
up some people are experiencing
cognitive dissonance and their taxes
really went up there's also a big
contingent that's just ignorant and they
don't understand that your refund
doesn't tell you whether your taxes went
up or went down the simplest example is
one that I have given before on the show
which is imagine for a moment that you
earn fifty thousand dollars a year just
to make it really simple you earn
$50,000 a year and last year
you paid ten thousand dollars in taxes
okay that's a 20% effective tax rate
50,000 and income 10,000 in taxes you
paid your effective rate was 20% now
imagine that at your job throughout the
year you had a total of $12,000 in taxes
withheld you made 50 grand your tax due
is 10 grand you paid 12 grand what
happens when you file your taxes you get
a $2,000 refund
great what was your actual tax tax do
ten thousand dollars imagine that the
next year
the withholding parameters change so
during that year you still make your
$50,000 you still owe $10,000 in actual
tax at the end of the year but you had
much less money withheld during the year
you had nine thousand dollars withheld
instead of twelve thousand dollars
withheld what happens when you file your
taxes you say IRS iearned 50k I've
already paid 9k I owe 10 meaning I cut
you a check for $1,000 did your tax rate
go up and down from year once a year to
no change in both years you had a 20%
effective tax rate the difference was
your withholding and that is increased
what is the subject of conversation
which is that as Fox and Friends
discussed on the program yesterday or
today and I will be covering tomorrow on
the David Pakman show
Fox News correctly pointed out that a
lot of what is happening is a result of
changes to withholding now where Fox is
going overboard is they're saying
they're laughing at people for not
realizing that maybe they should have
changed their withholdings when it was
the Trump administration that provided
guidance as to what those withholding
rates should be and Fox News is having a
great grand old time just laughing at
people saying stupid then they should
have figured that out but a lot of
people who are complaining about smaller
refunds are not necessarily paying more
in taxes that they've had it's that
they've had less withheld during the
year and now they're going to have to
either cut a check in some cases or they
are going to get a smaller refund now
the the problem with that is that we can
laugh at those people all we want as Fox
News decided to do because they were
apparently too dumb to figure that out
for themselves but for a lot of people
this is an economic problem right if you
for example had 50 fewer dollars
withheld during the year every single
month the total of 600 and that was your
tax refund last year and now you get no
refund that can actually be an economic
calamity for a lot of people because as
we know something like half of the
country doesn't even have the ability to
deal with an unexpected $400 expense
that's a real emergency so you know I
don't think it's actually something to
laugh at I am in the privileged position
I will admit that as as the the host of
the David Pakman show I earn a salary
during the year and I pay with holdings
but as an as one of one of the owners of
the business that is the david pakman
show at the end of the year I get a
distribution if we make money and so if
I end up having to as a result of those
changed withholdings cut a check to the
IRS when I file my taxes which by the
way my accountant says is increasingly
likely I'm going to have to do I just
got that distribution
as an owner of the business and I'm
going to be able to do that because I've
got the salary and the ownership most
people don't do that most people just
work for a living and so when they hear
that there's a new tax plan so to speak
and they see that they've got an extra
50 or 60 bucks a month that they are
getting that doesn't tell them
necessarily that they're actually going
to owe less in taxes it's just a change
in withholdings they may have to cut a
check that they can't afford and the
most important thing to remember about
that is that it's bad for the economy
okay because that is money that people
are not going to have to put into
businesses local businesses to put into
their local economy and it's money that
they are no longer going to be able to
spend because they've now got to cut a
check to the IRS so none of this is
funny and I do recognize the irony of
people who were sort of too ignorant to
understand the real implications of a
tax reform plan that they thought they
liked now coming back and saying where
did my refund go I get the irony but
it's bad for the economy and even if
those are trumpets I still feel bad for
them now where I stopped feeling bad is
if they decide to vote for the guy again
despite the the destructive impact that
he may have had on people as a result of
that tax plan but that's sort of a
different story for a different for a
different day so I was tweeting
yesterday with a bunch of different
people after seeing Donald Trump jr.
make this point on Twitter that your
refund doesn't tell you how much tax you
paid that's of course completely true
it's just completely ridiculous
that at this point in time once it's all
been said and done and whatever PR
benefit there was to 30 extra bucks in
people's paychecks has been undone by
the reality that that's money that's
just coming out of people's refunds now
seeing the inner circle of Trump going
around and saying hey listen you should
actually look at your total tax do not
at your refund it's it's ironic because
that's what Democrats have been saying
since January of 2018 January 2018
Democrats said you should be careful
about assume
that because you have less money being
withheld each month that that
necessarily correlates to a decrease in
your tax due because the Trump
administration calculated an
advantageous set of withholding tables
so that the media reports would be hey
everybody's got more money in their
paychecks myself included but only when
you file your taxes for the first time
will you actually know the real impact
of that and that is a very very
different story okay let me get to some
of the super chats that are starting to
come in super chat of course is the
dollar sign at the bottom of the chat
window if you have questions for me if
you have comments you want me to react
to using that dollar sign is the the way
to go I will mention just one more time
that I will open up the phone lines if
we get 10 new members during the
livestream okay I don't have all night
but if we do get 10 new members
relatively soon I'll open up the phone
lines there's two coupon codes available
the the best coupon code I think is the
birthday code the save 35 code we'd
launched this on February 2nd which was
the day of my birthday if you apply the
coupon code save 35 to the $60 a year
membership it will drop your membership
from $60 a year to $25 a year okay this
is an extraordinarily good deal
membership is well priced at the normal
prices and with a thirty five dollar
discount it's an extra good time to sign
up so when you go to the website david
pakman.com slash membership select the
$60 per year membership and then on the
second page of the signup process put in
the coupon code save 35 it'll drop the
cost of your membership from $60 to just
$25 a year 10 new members and I will
open up the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 we have one new member so far
Charles Cone who signed up using
coupon code nine more and I will indeed
open up the phone lines and when the
phone lines get opened there are no call
screeners trolls can get on people who
want to confront me about how I'm so
wrong about this or that political issue
everybody can do it
all right so we will I look forward to
doing that if indeed people want me to
okay let's see what we've got as far as
super chats here black wave 54 sent a
$0.99 super chat with no question or
comment thank you I appreciate it
the progressive voice sent a dollar
ninety nine super chat asking what's my
favorite TV show is it Big Bang Theory
no I don't think I've ever watched a
full episode of Big Bang Theory I
basically don't watch comedies I just I
find myself bored by most comedies
I think the last comedy show I watched
with any regularity was Curb Your
Enthusiasm actually and see what other
show am i watching now I'm watching
travelers Bendixon host of the Benjamin
Dickson show got me into travelers I'm
on season three of travelers just
finished up season three of man in the
high castle the Amazon original
excellent excellent show what else I'm
sort of anxiously waiting for the next
season of better call Saul and of mr.
robot
those are shows I like yeah those are a
few I guess the ones that come to mind
Paul Kyoko sends a $2.00 super chat no
question or comment thank you Alex and
Evan sends a $2.00 super chat asking
taxing the churches and their business
creates how much yeah I saw some figures
recently Alex about potentially the
amount of money that could be generated
as government revenue if we were to stop
tax exemptions for religious
organizations or even just for some
religious organizations and I don't
remember exactly what that number is but
it's a lot there's a lot of money
they're kind of hanging in the balance
Paul Kyoko says can you address Hauser's
law in taxation let me remind myself
what Hauser's law is I actually forgot
that's not the Laffer curve okay
Hauser's law Hauser's law is the
actually let's see if I can actually
even maybe pull this up on screen and we
can all look at it together
Hauser's law okay here we go
Hauser's law is the proposition that in
the United States federal tax revenues
since World War two have always been
approximately equal to nineteen and a
half percent of GDP regardless of wide
fluctuations in the marginal tax rate
historically since the end of World War
two federal tax receipts as a percentage
of GDP averaged 17 point nine percent
with a range from fourteen point four to
twenty point nine percent between 1946
and 2007 here's a chart and indeed you
know here's the problem with this so
there's a that this graph is an example
of one of the main ways that statistics
can appear sort of deceptive the
difference so this looks like wow look
federal tax receipts we have all sorts
of different tax reform marginal tax
rates are changed but tax receipts are
still in this very very narrow range
what you have to understand here is that
this y-axis is such that it appears as
though these are relatively
insignificant changes but when you
actually consider the difference between
if we go back to the numbers the
difference between twenty point nine
percent and fourteen point four percent
is almost 50 percent so this is a law
that seeks to assert that no matter what
happens with tax law actual receipts as
a percentage of GDP don't vary much but
that's only because of how this chart is
truncated or expanded in this particular
case and you're talking about 50 percent
variations and for something for an
entity the size of the United States the
difference between fourteen point four
and twenty twenty point nine percent is
actually huge so I'm just unsure about
the significance of Hauser's law
and and what sort of point they're
trying to make because that is a huge
huge huge variability okay a couple of
other new members I want to thank Jacob
Lee has signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership using the coupon code
save 35 save 35 is a beautiful thing it
drops a $60 membership to only 25 bucks
and if we get 10 new signups during the
stream I will open up the phone lines I
see a lot of people in the regular chat
who are mad at me about my comments
about Ilan Omar I am glad to answer
questions about that if we do indeed
open up the phone lines but we are only
20 percent of the way there we're
looking for 10 new members and if we get
that I will open up the phone lines okay
the progressive voice back in there with
a dollar ninety nine super chat asking
what are some things you do in your
spare time I play drums I read a ton I
play chess I travel I what else do I do
I go to the gym a lot of David Pakman
show viewers by the way at my gym it's
now it's it's uh it's becoming a thing
where I've met a whole bunch of people
there who you know I'm trying to work on
my lats and people are talking to me
about the State of the Union or whatever
but yeah I go to the gym as well okay
platypi with underscores sends a two
Australian dollar super chat would the
USA ever swap to rank-choice voting I
would love it and I know that every time
this comes up some people the concern
trolls will say but David what about
rank-choice voting possibly giving a
victory to a candidate who wasn't
anyone's first choice that's been dealt
with there are a bunch of models for
Instant Runoff voting which prevent that
from happening I I think that the forces
that control how our system works don't
want rank-choice voting because it's one
of the main ways along with campaign
finance reform for third party
candidates to become relevant and to
potentially gain more power so I would
like to think that rank
voting is possible but the establishment
doesn't want it to Sean G's said or guys
with a five-dollar super chat biggest
super chat of the evening Fox News polls
showed that a majority of their viewers
want higher taxes on million dollar
earners and higher why do they vote
Republican or against their interests
then we've talked about this for a very
long time there are sort of first-order
and second-order and third-order issues
in terms of what our voting issues and
that is something that for a long time
has led to people not voting for their
own best interests because of sort of
higher moral priorities I've been
reading Jonathan Heights book what is
this now I forgot the name of it I think
it's the rational mind and he talks
about a lot of the research that shows
that a lot of the reasons we claim to
support or oppose a policy we believe
that it is from a sort of rational
reasoning logical reasoning perspective
that we have decided that we are for or
against or supporting a certain
candidate or policy but that
increasingly what the what the research
shows us is that when people hear about
abortion when people hear about tax the
rich or whatever there's an initial
reaction that is based more on passion
and gut and we are then finding post hoc
rationalizations and I think that that
plays a big role in why a lot of people
are voting one way but then claiming to
support policies that we would imagine
would lead them lead them to make
different decisions at the ballot box
Jacob Lee also a YouTube channel member
Jacob is now two-thirds of the new
members during the stream this is sort
of it's pathetic how poorly it's going
today but Jacob now I think we have to
count that twice we're looking for 10
new members Jacob is both a new website
member and a new YouTube member and in
addition to Charles Kohn that is now 3
of 10 and if indeed we get to 10 new
members during the
dream I'll open up the phone lines and I
see a lot in the chat people angry with
me about AIPAC and Ilana Mawr and all
sorts of other stuff I'm glad to talk
about all of that once we open up the
phone lines and you can call in and call
me out on it I'm ready okay let's see
here what other super chats do we have
elias hakonsen with a 50 Swedish kronor
super chat how much is that in u.s.
dollars I don't know offhand it's it
like 5 bucks maybe Elias says what's a
policy prescription that would do a lot
of good that nobody's talking about my
vote is slashing not in my backyard
regulations you know a very small
financial transaction a speculative
financial transaction tax would do a lot
of good and we know from very good
research that has been done that a lot
of the Wall Street speculation that goes
on is of no societal or economic benefit
it's not like for example going to the
local what's a what's a nice quaint and
archaic example it's not like going to
the local metal Smith and having them
make you an oven or something like that
where you are funding the labor of the
metal Smith and then the metal Smith can
then go and take that money and spend it
at the local grocery store and it has
this multiplier effect as it's called in
economics a lot of the particularly
derivative and other more speculative
financial instruments the money that is
generated there it is generating money
in a sense and people are making a lot
of money from it but it's not providing
any kind of a broader economic benefit
putting a small transaction tax on those
mechanisms that are more speculative
would have a huge huge would be a huge
benefit to the to the economy at large
let me say thank you to Alex beard Alex
beard has signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership alex used the code say
35 which means that Alex got a $60
membership for just 25 bucks and that
means that we are now at four out of ten
we are now just six new members away
from me saying we are opening up the
phone lines and I'm excited it seems
like a lot of anger in the chat and I'm
glad to hear from people okay Jacob Lee
with a ten dollar super chat yes
unfortunately I'm from that that Lee
family the one that founded and then
disgraced the country thereafter hoping
I can eventually enter politics from
Oklahoma and change the state to
progressive did I is Jacob saying that
he's part of robert e lee Civil War
general robert e lee's family i that may
be what he's saying i don't i can't
think of any other family that is not
last named lee that we would think of as
that lee family but i appreciate the
support
jacob thank you Sean G's or Sean guys
I'm a big reader myself any authors you
recommend yeah I mean I you know we I
should do an entire podcast just about
books someday but it'll get a hundred
downloads and it'll have been you know
maybe an exercise in futility but right
now I mean I'll just tell you what I'm
reading right now for nonfiction right
now I just finished Haruki Murakami's
book hard-boiled Wonderland and the end
of the world the books actually from
1985 it was translated in the early 90s
by Alfred Birnbaum and I just finished
it very very good book I am now reading
one of eric ambler books that he wrote
under a pen name eric ambler is one of
my absolute favorite authors in the sort
of genre of john lecarre a and raymond
chandler and all of all of those
anything by eric ambler i recommend that
you read and then I just got Elliot
peppers novel that has not even been
released yet
Elliot pepper writes really really good
sort of like I don't want to be
offensive and I we follow each other on
on Twitter and I hate mischaracterizing
authors books but I consider them sort
of techno thrillers and I recently read
uh borderless and bandwidth by Elliot
pepper and the new one is breech it's
not even released yet but he was kind
enough to send me a pre-release copy so
those are the three fiction books that
I've just read in him reading nonfiction
right now I'm reading escape from camp
14 which just a Twitter follower
recommended to me last week I tweeted
what good nonfiction book should I read
someone recommended camp escape from
camp 14 which is the now known to be not
totally accurate story of a North Korean
work camp prisoners escape and I'm
almost done with it it's just it's a
total page-turner and really really
interesting and as I mentioned I'm also
reading Jonathan Heights book the
rational mind or the rational brain I
believe it's called it's a little bit
older now but very good that's just a
little bit you know I could go on all
day about about what I'm reading okay
let me let's see where we are we've got
a couple more members so Justin Val
quartz is a new $2 a month patron we are
counting patrons towards our goal of 10
supporters to open the phone lines that
gets us to number 5 and Mark Everett has
signed up on our website with the coupon
code save 35 mark just got a delightful
$60 membership for only 25 bucks because
he used the code SAVE 35 that is 6 so we
are 60% of the way to opening the phone
lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 keep them
coming
ok platypi is back saying I I just I
just got back to Australia from my first
u.s. trip and I'm currently working on a
video about my experience I'm hoping to
get feedback from you once completed
please yeah I have a lot of requests all
the time for people people who want to
just get my feedback on a video there's
limited time but feel free to email it
to me when you have it and I'll make
every effort to check it out elias
hakonsen is back saying well my day
trading just got you 100 swedish kronor
how much is that let's see if i can
figure that out SEK 2 USD that's that's
actually confusing you
- D - SEK is a better way to do it okay
so it's nine point two seven Swedish
Krona is one dollar so that's about 10
bucks Thank You Elias I appreciate that
but what can I say
skål Krogh says is it bad for your watch
time if I watch your videos and fast
forward I like you so much better in
fast-forward that's a really good
question so watch time is a big
indicator on YouTube it's not just views
that matter but it's what percentage of
your videos are people watching and how
many minutes of video are people
watching my understanding is that if I
have a 10 minute video and you watch it
at 2x speed meaning it only takes you
five minutes to watch it I believe that
that still counts as 10 minutes of watch
time so no speed me up I don't I don't
mind it all
Keith Klem with a 5 dollar super chat
says no question just moved by all the
haters posting don't give this ad
hominem of choice more money and three
thousand four hundred and ninety two
hatreds cry are people saying that in
the chat let me see here are people
actually saying let's scroll up a little
bit maybe I can make this bigger and we
can take a look at it together just
briefly are people saying not to give me
money pop off my boy progressive so
people are angry with progressive voice
David give a shout out to your new
patron Benjamin Netanyahu can't imagine
he'd give me money I've been arguing
against him for years at this point what
else
Trump is really black he's wearing white
face yeah I'm not seeing people saying
not to give me money here but David do
you use bots I don't even know for what
but no but what would we even use BOTS
for for for posting tweets or I don't
know yes robert e lee interesting okay
robert e lee family member is in the
audience david as the personality of a
bicycle seat yeah you know if i notice
someone it's probably because you're
being really annoying and I saw that
Larry Cooper was posting stuff before we
even started if this entire endeavor is
just so bad for you
Larry I don't even know why you're here
Saul Cruz challenges me to a chess match
I would do that I'm David Pakman on li
chess and I would play but I think we're
kind of working towards we're working
towards opening up the phone lines so I
don't know if the audience really wants
to see that today okay let me sort of
shrink the chat a little bit more here
again and let me say thank you - okay so
Jacob Lee is now Jacob Lee is now triple
threat Jacob has signed up for a YouTube
channel membership for a website
membership and on patreon jacob is now a
five dollar-a-month patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
that's seven out of ten we're looking
for ten new members or supporters of any
kind and I'll open up the phone lines at
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty I have the phone line ready
to go but I will I have to wait if I say
we need ten subscribers I need to wait
otherwise what's the point of the entire
thing okay platypi says that they will
make their video three minutes long just
for me so that i will review it okay I
think that's that's fair that's a fair
trade
Sabrina Zafar says who or what are your
inspirations and influences you know I
don't know if it's my lack of
sentimentality or what but I couldn't
tell you I don't my inspirations and
influences I feel like I need to have
some kind of set PR friendly answer to
that question because it's been asked
before and I never have a good answer I
don't know the people of the world or my
are my inspiration Sabrina I met Sabrina
by the way at politican I believe this
is Sabrina from Boston College who I met
in person at politican in a scrum of all
sorts of people who had questions and
met some Argentinians at politican I
think that's the same Sabrina thanks
Sabrina good to see you here Jacob Lee
says hey a David Pakman show yes I am
from a branch that dates back to the
sibling of Henry light Horsley I don't
know who that is but is
that that connects to robert e lee and
it's the it's the same it's the same
family very interesting
Joshua Carr Josh it's been a while since
I've heard from you good - good to see
you in the chat $20 super chat that's
the top super chat of the evening Joshua
says David always good to have the same
voice on YouTube no question keep up the
good work
I'll also sign up for a YouTube
membership let's get to ten and open up
the phone lines and indeed Joshua
immediately signing up for a YouTube
subscription that gets us to eight did I
skip seven no I think we were at seven
and now we are at eight eighty percent
of the way there you get two more new
members patrons YouTube channel members
I will open up the phone lines at six
one seven eight three zero 47 50 and
from what am people are just on fire in
the chat wanting to talk to me about all
sorts of stuff people saying Israel is
an illegitimate state I think that that
is a losing argument for anybody who
wants Israeli policy to change you are
not going to win that one
Hasan jf was really looking forward to
seeing Kyle and I debate Ben Shapiro
Charlie Kirk or Candace Owens at
Politico if they didn't chicken out yeah
you know I don't even know if they did
chicken now at this point politican was
so poorly organized that when when they
said that some of those individuals are
opting not to participate it's not even
clear to me that they were actually
pitched those debates I think that in
some cases they just never responded to
politican I don't know if Candace Owens
is playing coy with it but she tweeted
to one of my followers recently who is
David Parkman when they said why didn't
you debate David and that may be true
that she might be playing dumb or that
may be true she may have no idea who I
am so I don't know what the truth is of
any of that stuff okay the progressive
voice is in the super chat with a dollar
ninety-nine super shot what was the
backstory of the Instagram picture
Kyle I presume he means kolinsky in Los
Angeles I don't remember the picture
exactly I remember posting a picture
with Kyle just hanging out at politican
I don't think there was backstory it was
just let's post a picture and and see
what happens and from what I recall it
did really well if you want to see the
picture that the progressive voice is
talking about follow me on Instagram it
David Pakman and by the way I just want
to let people know let me see if it's
still going on here um on the show
Instagram account which is david pakman
show I've been taking questions
throughout the day I do this like every
other Wednesday and it is still there so
if you have any questions for me that
maybe I would answer you can follow
david pakman show on instagram and post
them there Jacob Lee says yes Henry
lighthouse Lee was the father of Robert
Ely so my branch diverged slightly
before his existence very very
interesting interesting and appreciate
the support and all the super chats
Jacob we have a new patron alex beard
who also signed up for membership
tonight that gets us to nine new
supporters during the stream we're
almost there
do people want me to open up the phone
lines if people do I will but we need
just one new either website subscriber
patron or YouTube channel member which
you can do by using the join button I
think it's down there below the below
the livestream and then we will go ahead
and get the phone lines opened okay I
was just taking a scan through the chat
here people want the phone lines open
here's an example this is you see Jacob
Lee now has this cool david pakman show
logo whenever he participates in the JA
in the chat that's one of the benefits
conferred by membership people talking
about abolishing Jewish supremacy and
just people are obsessed with Jews it's
really weird
you know I was actually talk this is
kind of interesting I was talking to
someone the other day and we were
talking about anti-semitism and
anti-semitic conspiracy conspiracy
theories and this sort of stuff
and they pointed out something that is
really sort of notable I guess we would
say about anti-semitism which is that it
goes beyond some of the particular
characterizations of other minority
groups that lead to discrimination and
Prejudice so like for example there's
the stereotype that exists a lot of
people are like angry with Hispanic
people because they're quote taking our
jobs
or they are quote leeching off welfare
how the same people that are taking your
job or getting welfare despite working
doesn't really make sense there they
conflict but that's like one meme that
you see out there you see with with
black people you see the so-called crime
realists who say hey black people are
inherently criminals and that's the
problem with black people with Jews it's
often these sort of just like amorphous
ideas of Jewish supremacy and
conspiracies about the protocols of the
Elders of Zion and all this stuff it
goes beyond even not that any of the
reasons people dislike Hispanic people
or black people or whoever make sense
but at least they have an internal logic
that that there's like a specific reason
people are citing a lot of the
anti-semitism like some of these posts
that we're seeing even depressingly on
on our chat are just so vague you know
it stopped Jewish supremacy what is they
didn't give me a break
okay we're gonna open up the phone lines
and the reason that we're going to do
that is that we have all sorts of new
supporters and patrons and stuff like
that
that I'm going to thank right now so I
am opening up the phone lines now at six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty but before you can start queuing
as people like to say mostly the British
I think but I want to thank Deakin UCLA
who is a
new member debar new who is a new member
Heath Cooper is a new member
jared is a new patron and I think that
is it yeah I believe that that is it so
I'm gonna go over to the phone lines and
see what people have on their minds 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 I am getting on lot on the
line here let's see here ok
and a lot of people holding already
let's see let's go first just because
international is interesting and and it
could be very late where this person is
calling from I'm gonna go first to the
caller from country code 49 what country
code is 49 I know yeah that's you where
were you calling from I'm iChatting I'm
calling from Germany I called again
and I quote a few weeks ago but no I'm
here again and yeah what's going on
great and ok so I was the question I
have today more economically
um about Argentina country if I remember
right and why is that
Argentina struggle so much with
inflation and other connected problems
with the economy regardless of the
government if it is the right wing or
left wing it seems that this is a
consistent problem but yeah it's void I
mean this site requires like 30 years of
history to look at but there's a long
history of outrageous inflation it
happens during left wing and and during
centrist administrations in Argentina
there were missteps with the currency
for a while the peso was pegged one to
one to the dollar that was a train wreck
now there has been this massive
devaluation there have been missteps
with the soy industry in Argentina I
mean it's like it would take so long to
explain but it's it's you know the the
vulture loans are also a problem it's a
mess down there and I feel really bad
because a lot of my
family is dealing with it every single
day have you any idea what what to do to
change the situation no no unfortunately
most of the suggestions that I read are
only partially getting at the heart of
the issues and also very difficult to
implement politically particularly with
the degree of corruption that many
recent administrations in Argentina have
had so I unfortunately don't know what
the best plan is and that's not a good
thing at all yes it's extraordinarily
depressing yeah great to hear from you
appreciate the call I'm gonna let you go
because I've got a bunch of people here
holding okay let's see let's go to the
267 area code caller from 267 who's this
where you're calling from is that me
yeah that's you
hi David my name is Sean guys I'm from
jamison pennsylvania bum originally from
Philadelphia cool okay so your last name
is pronounced guys yes it is yes don't
worry about Jesus David I've been
hurting hearing that since second grade
don't look at it and it's going to first
talk to me so I have a question
um I thought about this the other day
and I noticed that if you I'm sure I
mean everybody pays attention to Donald
Trump's a Twitter feed and you know he's
able to call out you know people even on
the stupidest things like calling you
know Chuck Todd sleepy-eyed Chuck yep
calling now you know it's not like
Hillary Clinton all the time during 2016
like so you you know who he's able to
point out you know and installed on
Twitter but I noticed um that he doesn't
really insult Bernie Sanders the only
thing he ever really said what Bernie
Sanders was you know even if he's in a
wheelchair I'll have an election with
him or something like that
and I'm thinking does he does he not go
after Bernie Sanders because he sort of
knows that there are voters of his in
places like the Rust Belt who would've
voted for Bernie if it was Bernie versus
Trump I don't think so no I don't think
so and the reason why is I just I don't
I don't think
that it's true that he you know the
whole crazy Bernie thing was a thing for
a while all of Bernie's ideas are crazy
and he I think he has even said even if
it had been Bernie I still would have
crushed him so I just I've not seen
Trump shying away from criticizing
Bernie the way you're suggesting ok yeah
but I think it's just even when you but
I'm not talking about like if you hear
him you know like Bernie during MLK Day
during the speech you know blamele
called out you know Donald Trump a
racist you know and you know any other
people it's all cuz I noticed the same
also with AOC he hasn't come down
sweater and said specifically anything
about AOC yeah that's more interesting
I'm more interested in that because that
one is more of a question mark to me but
with the Bernie one I mean listen well
we'll know for sure if Bernie declares
that he's running and we'll see whether
or not Trump is afraid of criticizing
him publicly but so far i I'm more
interested in why he hasn't been
critical of AOC rather than than Bernie
because I think he has been critical of
Bernie I just think he's afraid of the
immensely popular like someone who seems
to have more media coverage more Twitter
followers and he does because you know
that could be that could be I'll pay
closer attention to it appreciate the
call thank you no problem thank you
great okay let's see who else we've got
on the phone let's go to the five-seven
one area code caller from five seven one
who's there hi David there's been a
handle from Columbia hey what's going on
oh good good I just want to hear you
thought some trance comments on sending
the military to Venezuela you know we've
been good allies of the state's favor
and in the case of a military attack on
Venezuela he would surely send troops to
call me and station them here so I want
to know what you think about what he
said if he is serious about threat you
know I apologize what what did Trump say
about troops in Venezuela this is this
something recent that I just haven't
seen yet well you know that president
Duque is now in the state's they have
a mean thing there and he said that he
was not discarding a military option in
Venezuela and in that case he would send
troops decision them in Colombia got it
okay yeah I mean I'm against that
ii-i've just I'm the United States
presence in Latin America has been an
absolute and total disaster and I would
be against that the only exception would
be if indeed there is a defensive effort
in coalition in Latin America and the
u.s. is part of that coalition then okay
but anything other than that I would be
I can't think of other circumstances
under which I would be in favor of the
u.s. getting involved militarily in
Latin America I mean he's a madman yes I
think that he actually does have some
people around him who recognize that the
places where Trump has thought about
sending the military are really a bad
idea and some would potentially be
political suicide so even though the guy
is unhinged I have some last optimism
that there are people around him who
just wouldn't allow him to do it okay
great great to hear from you thank you
let's go to the eight five eight area
code caller from eight five eight what's
on your mind today
hello
I heard you unmute eight five eight are
you are you there eight five eight is
gone okay uh let's see let's go to the
nine to five area code caller from nine
to five who's there hello yeah that's
you okay cool oh my name is stages um
they just te Jas te Jas all right I like
that isn't it my house which is how you
say Texas in Spanish yeah kind of all
right cool
so my today I was just I was actually on
I'm wondering about the topic
that you brought with the taxes okay now
some concerns really wondering about
like ALC
70% marginal tax rate and I was
wondering if that would really be
effective as to really be effective as
to how we're gonna be able to tax the
rich and you know get money out of them
so that we can fund social welfare
programs okay but I mean the thing is
that lots of these rich people have very
high incomes but they also have like
that in sorry they have very high
networks but they have like low incomes
which is hard to tax like for example
just Bezos he earned forty billion
dollars in net worth it only had income
of like eighty thousand in 2017 yep but
what other effective methods could be
used in order to UM you know get more
taxing for the government in order to
find safety net programs so there's two
options and I'm not assessing the
popularity of these but I'm just
identifying two options one possibility
is doing some kind of a wealth tax and
elizabeth warren has put out a plan on
that the other possibility is changing
the long term capital gains rate so that
passive income the likes of which is
often taxed at significantly lower rates
than income tax rates would be taxed at
a higher rate there's a proposal to
raise from 15 to 20 percent which is
still quite reasonable and would still
save people money versus earned income
which would raise a lot of money so
those are a couple of ideas that have
been floated which i think are
reasonable it's you know the political
viability remains to be seen
yeah all right thank you okay thanks for
calling in good question appreciate it
let's go next to the two four zero area
code caller from two four zero go ahead
yeah that's you so listen something just
clicked and now you sound like you're
underwater did you plug in a Bluetooth
headset or something
oh man you're just fading you're coming
in and out let's let's do speaker off
headphones off and see if we can get
your question is it better now yes it is
uh yeah that my speaker on because I'm
doing my French homework right now oh
all right
well if you're doing French then I'll
allow it
so my question was actually about the
Israel Palestine issue right now okay I
was wondering what your take is on it
and like just your general opinion about
it about what specifically are you
asking me like I myself I don't think
I'm very informed on the issue like I
just have a general background knowledge
on the Israel Palestine issue like I
know that Israel was created on the last
day of the British Mandate that they had
over Palestine so I was just wondering
like the current like what possible
solutions do you think it would be well
I mean listen to go from the history to
the solution it's extraordinarily
difficult but I've laid out what what my
plan would be a couple of times in
videos that go into some detail and I
would just encourage you to check those
out that some of the things that I think
will need to happen are settlements
which are illegal obviously need to stop
immediately and a lot of them are going
to need to be undone if there's going to
be a peace deal the blockade on Gaza is
going to need to be opened but there's
going to be need to be some kind of
mechanism in there to ensure that if
indeed weapon making supplies are
continuing or start going back in that
something can be done
control of the good old the old city of
Jerusalem is going to be a big point of
contention
I believe that big picture East
Jerusalem is going to need to become a
permanent part of the Palestinian
territories or a state that is created
in the future
but the Jewish quarter of the old city
is going to need to remain under under
Israeli control I mean you know the none
of these things are unique it's just
sort of taking eliminating non-starters
and figuring out like okay what are just
the basic things that are going to need
to be there if there's going to be any
progress on peace and by the way
Netanyahu has to go and Hamas has to go
there's not going to be any serious
progress here with Hamas in charge of
Gaza nor with Benjamin Netanyahu in
charge of Israel okay I was just
wondering because I have some friends
who are from Israel and you know a lot
of arguments like that just spark at the
dinner table and okay good we'll check
out my videos on it I I appreciate the
call great too great to hear from you
let's go next to where do we want to go
let's go to the five one two area code
caller from five one two and the number
by the way for people asking is six one
seven eight three zero 4750 caller from
five one two what's going on hello yeah
this is Steve Austin Tejas love your
show think he's really good the previous
caller kind of teed me up here I think
for what I'm going to say and what I'm
going to ask you I saw on one of your
shows like an aside that you apparently
don't approve of the BDS movement
boycott divestment sanctions on Israel
it's not that I don't approve of all
movement I mean I'm you know people I'm
fine with people choosing to do boycotts
I am NOT a supporter of it personally
well I would just say this is the
statement I would make which I have
written down but a combination of BDS
outside Israel in a discipline
nonviolent action inside Israel and
Palestine I think is the only realistic
way forward out of a totally gridlocked
situation that's highly dangerous
and lethal to world peace if it's left
unresolved I don't think it's stable for
the long term and I don't think
targeting Israel in that way is about
them being uniquely bad at least as far
as I'm concerned like some people will
say well why not target China why not
target Nepal etc if any synthetic just
have this tactic I just do such things
because you're sort of you're saying it
anti-semitic merely to talk about I
think I think some of the many of the
defenders of well the State of Israel in
some cases and its defenders will say
why single out this nation alone among
nations in the world as if they're
somehow uniquely bad on their human
rights record when there's so many more
worse and so because yeah first you said
it's wrong to say that merely having
this conversation is anti-semitic but
then when I asked you who's saying that
you said well some people are saying
that it's wrong to single Israel out but
those are two different things I said
who is saying well merely talking about
this is anti-semitic cuz I haven't seen
that well honestly I want I would say I
would preface a couple of things my case
here is earth first off I would say I am
Pro Zionist in the sense that I believed
Jewish nationalism is valid okay and I
believe I believe the original Zionist
movement was democratic in nature and
for Israel to remain that way which i
think is vital for its own survival
because no country can stand alone
against the world
I think I think you know there there's
going to have to be this respect for
human rights but but I also think it's
human nature like nobody's going to give
up anything any territory or any
prerogatives without pressure and so I
think the BDS
tactic gives nonviolent coercion and
outlet for anger among Palestinians and
a way for people of good will who live
in Israel live around the world can can
pressure non violently and effectively
pressure I think I got it okay party so
the bargaining table but idea but also
easier that what your Steve you just
you're going I think I get the point
you're going on and on what would be
then so let's say a lot of obviously
these aren't going to boycott Israel
because they live there they go to
Israeli grocery stores and they have
Israeli phone service and all of that
stuff so people around the world boycott
Israel Israeli products I guess so like
what happens next
how does it work who does it bring to
the table and in what way will it make
them more willing to negotiate with
whoever it is they're going to negotiate
with well well I I said a combination of
BDS on the outside of the region and
disciplined nonviolent action on the
inside of the region and I think the
Palestinian authorities could could
discipline the nonviolent action I think
they could do that and and so I think
that's the only way forward because
Steve you see I see are saying Hamas
would be maybe no no the Palestinian
Authority how come you've already got it
got it in the West yeah yes yeah and I
think you know it's like no Hamas is
well I don't know maybe I I live here I
don't live there so maybe if they're
gonna be to say but I just from reading
this stuff and looking at things it
looks to me like you don't give up
anything unless it's under duress
normally human beings don't yet if the
other side is using violence against you
well then you don't want to reward the
violence and so when in a time of
Israel never bargains and then in a time
of frenzy they really don't want to
bargain because it would be rewarding
violence and and then when Israel
arguably is preemptively givin up some
territory for you know preemptively
I guess for strategic reasons like
southern Lebanon and Gaza well sure
enough me the other side says well
that's because we were violence and it
worked so let's say amplify our Bible
and I just think it's a really dangerous
situation so yeah yeah I think I better
way to go yeah I just think you know
it's but at this point there might be
something we could point to that has has
been achieved by it and you know other
than some resolutions where some places
are like we're not gonna do business
with Israel I I just don't see it
getting us anywhere closer to where I
want to be which is serious peace talks
the other thing I would also mention is
you know there's a significant if you're
really gonna do it you've got to do it
and if you're gonna boycott Israel then
it's got to include all medical devices
from Israel it has to include you know
the intellectual property and medical
treatments that have been developed
there and nobody's really willing to do
that that I've seen when those are the
superior thing so you also need to be
able to be consistent and really do it
not just like I'm not going to buy
SodaStream I'll get Poland spring
seltzer water but when it comes to other
things I'm totally fine you know well I
guess cultural boycotts are problematic
I do feel squeamish about that you know
like like there should be contact
cultural contact between Israel and the
rest of the world don't think there's
any risk that that will change all right
Steve I'm gonna let you go I've got just
a ton of people holding here and let's
see all right let's go - lets go - Alex
Alex is on and I've got a note here that
Alex just calls or sometimes interesting
what's on your mind today Alex hey David
hey what's
thanks for taking my call thank you hey
so in the previous call I made you
brought up the concept of externalities
which is another debate and I wanted to
ask
well Dave what's the debate about
externalities whether they exist the
debate about pricing things according to
negative externalities okay
and my question is if it were 1,000 BC
would you price like fire
according to externalities like firewood
because it causes smoke which can cause
respiratory diseases and would you price
it according to that why does it need to
be a thousand BC doesn't fire would also
cause those problems today yeah yeah
exactly
it doesn't need to be a thousand BC oh
but it's just a hypothetical example I
don't know how I would price firewood
I'm not sure why what what's the what's
the broader point I guess that you're
trying to make I'm just I'm trying to
make the point that externalities are
just kind of an arbitrary worthless
concept that well hold on but so those
are two different in arbitrary is one
thing and worthless is a different one I
think that arbitrary I mean listen
arbitrary you may not be able to get
100% accuracy in assessing as
externalities but to say that there are
betrayer I don't think is right we might
just have a hard time being exactly
accurate you know what I mean right
okay so arbitrary I don't think is the
right term okay well we can't really get
an accurate worth they're saying we
can't get an accurate we can get pretty
close though okay so so like I don't
think that that's really a good argument
now is worthless as an interesting one I
mean here's the the value I see and
being aware of externalities imagine
that we have two competing I don't know
we have two competing meat proteins that
we can eat
they both are equally tasty
they confer the same amount of protein
and fat and cholesterol and whatever
else they're the same in every way
except one of them requires way more you
know water or transportation it comes
from further away so it's releasing more
pollution into the atmosphere
whether we are a hundred percent right
in assessing exactly what the cost of
that externality is wouldn't you say
that it's not worthless like that's a
relevant thing to think about if I'm
completely neutral in terms of taste and
health value between two meat proteins
and one is worse for the environment
that seems worthwhile to me doesn't it
well it's not really how prices work I
mean if for that example no but hold on
a second that's a different argument the
question the question that I have is in
what way would it be worthless to
consider the externalities that's what
you first alleged you said it's
worthless
okay well explain to me how they're
worth something because if I'm
indifferent if we ignore the
externalities and we just say here's two
types of meat protein here's how they
taste and here's how much how many how
many grams of protein they have not
having the additional information that
there is an environmental cost that is
greater for one of those than not the
other
I now have incomplete information I'm
making a more informed decision and one
that accounts for the negative
externalities in a way that's better for
the planet by knowing that one of these
proteins is much worse for the
environment that seems relevant that is
a value right but how prices work is it
would be priced higher because more
transportation would be involved and
that is only if you are talking in an
actual free market where those
externalities are borne by the producer
and paid for by the consumer the you're
right in a sense but the problem is that
in the economic system that we have a
lot of those externalities are so
specialized and it ends up being paid
for by taxpayers and that's where it
becomes problematic what what do you
mean paid for by taxpayer so for example
a company that is a for-profit company
and they do fracking for example right
in North Carolina I think this is an
example from six months ago
if you account for the frequency with
which there is an accident which
requires significant spending in order
to do the cleanup if that is accounted
for and that cost is borne by the
company that would be one scenario but
what ends up happening is that it ends
the cleanup cost ends up being borne by
the taxpayers through state agencies
that then have to go and clean up the
disaster so only if that externality is
borne by the for-profit company with the
perfect pricing mechanism you described
actually function but if it's the
taxpayers who are paying for the cleanup
if the profit is for the corporation and
the cleanup costs are socialized among
taxpayers the pricing theory you
mentioned doesn't hold true okay well
that's how prices worked those wouldn
tellyou going to what I'm telling you is
it's not the way prices would work in a
free market where negative externalities
are actually priced in is what you're
describing but that's just not the real
world right but that in that case that
was saying I guess a rights violation
and say if I punch you in the face is
that an externality no it's a rights
violation does that have anything to do
with what we're talking about listen
Alex I'm gonna let you go I appreciate
that you didn't interrupt me almost at
all during today's call but I think
we've gotten sort of as far as we as far
as we can hear okay let me say thanks to
Sully Devon who has signed up for a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership let's check in with a couple
of other people let's go to the five one
eight area code caller from five one
eight who's there hey David Albany hey
Adam what's going on
I guess my question is I've noticed that
with George Bush jr.
there's been a lot of speculation that
most of his presidency was sort of
dictated by his vice president Dick
Cheney and now with Trump it seems like
that might also be a similar situation
developing there do you think this is
going to be a recurring pattern going
forward for the GOP where the face of
the presidency is sort of like the good
old boy and the Vice President sort of
handles all of the internal affairs of
state you know I'm not convinced that
Mike Pence is in charge right now I mean
what first of all so I would say two
things about that that I would kind of
want to follow up on one is I think if
Pence were actually in charge Trump
wouldn't have done half of the stupid
stuff that he's done because Pence
recognizes that a lot of the things he
does are really really dumb but more
importantly like what Paul it doesn't
suit Trump's personality to be
manipulated by pens he's much more the
type of guy who would be manipulated in
a less obvious way like for example via
a 30 year relationship with Russia but
putting that aside like what specific
thing has Trump done that strikes you
more as like pence is doing than Trump's
doing well honestly it seems like he
hasn't done much himself which is why I
believe that perhaps Pence is doing like
actual work behind the scenes because a
lot of the proposals Trump has put forth
have just really flown on their face but
okay so like what's an example of
something pence got done uh you know
what your you might be right about that
it's not a god I mean I'm open to what
you're saying I'm just trying to think
like what are the yeah I mean we you
know the the Republican house before
they lost control of it was putting
through a bunch of stuff and we'd
reported on a lot of it I just don't
know that pence was that involved I feel
like pence is steering clear and just
kind of letting this disaster happen you
might be right about that actually all
right appreciate the call thank you I'll
think about that more and and follow-up
let's see here
let's go to the 7 1 8 area code a 7 1 8
Brooklyn or Boston I never remember 7 1
8 are you there hello data yes I didn't
think I would actually get picked up on
for this
I'm calling for Queens from
New York City apologize for the Brooklyn
comment then what I said I thought seven
one eight was Brooklyn but it's Queens
an iPod if that's a fact like all the
outer boroughs no one cares about New
York City yeah yeah yeah yeah anyway I
was calling because me and a lot of the
audience we're not happy with your
coverage of the Ilhan Omar situation
okay I don't particularly have my own
solution for what I want to do is Israel
okay I would like to not do human rights
violations on Palestine good a lot of my
camasta it'll stop like exploding things
that's what I would like there but good
I feel are very bothered by a tax
influence it's up to seven other packs
but when I was concerned about with the
Ilhan Omar coverage mm-hmm I didn't feel
she said anything anti-semitic right and
I suggest you I also said it you do I
want to make sure you remember that in
the segment I also said I wasn't
alleging that she said something
anti-semitic right so we're all on the
same page yeah but you talked about
anti-semitic tropes that's right I did
RB could you be a little more specific
like what how did she say something that
could be like I know what you're talking
about with like I guess dog-whistle type
deals but I didn't see that like what
specific like phrases well I already I
mean listen I already did the entire
segment yesterday or the day before you
didn't agree with it now you're
basically just asking me to repeat so I
here's the question I have for you
because I actually am super interested
in this how what should my response be
as the host of the show when there is
negative feedback to a segment that I do
like I've gotten you know some tweets
from people and I've seen messages in
the chat from people saying hey we don't
like what you said about Ilan Omar so
like what should I do about that what
would you advise me to do about but like
a brat like phrases poorly ever sorry
that's it I'm not trying to attack you
for the segment I just right now is like
what's the segment with twice I didn't
like I couldn't see what you're really
pointing to but I guess by more of an
actual question for a while a call it's
like
if not DDS now I agree with what you
said earlier that Hamas and then Yahoo
are both issues that are stopping
negotiation but yeah let's say you were
Donald Trump right now how would you try
to get Israel and Palestine whoever may
be in charge a negotiating table if not
I don't know that the current players
are the right players to negotiate and
Trump is the exact wrong person to do it
so like that by the way it's not even
totally under to me that it's the
responsibility of an American president
to be super involved in those
negotiations I mean historically there
have been American presidents and other
political players who were well suited
to the task and if both the Israeli and
Palestinian sides are open to having a
you know the participation of someone
from the US fine but I also think we
should be challenging the idea that it's
up to the American president to
negotiate do you see what I'm saying
yeah I know what you're saying it really
shouldn't have been our situation but I
looked at it like it was kind of we got
involved and we're just kind of like we
give a lot of support to Israel so just
kind of chain to it I guess would be the
way I would phrase it well would you
apply that same standard to any country
we give aid to like are we particularly
chained to you know I don't know picked
pick your country yeah I guess I could
like you could say that we're chained to
like Japan because we thought the
agreement that we have a military base
there we you know I guess air quotes
protects them we uh we still have the
countries in NATO but I guess I guess
where would be like what would you do
from America what would you want America
to do in that situation would you try to
just send in aid I would try to start
eating I would try to eat listen well
it's well it's Netanyahu and Hamas I
don't know that you're really going to
make any significant progress because
Netanyahu doesn't want peace and Hamas
doesn't want peace so if you don't have
willing participants you're not going to
get anywhere but let's
assume for a second that I was in a
position to actually have some influence
I would try to negotiate individually
with to try to get some concessions like
for example trying to ease some element
of the blockade with Gaza to start maybe
opening things up there to create a
situation where in six months we might
be a step closer to in good-faith
negotiations I might start looking at a
definitive decision to stop all
settlements and to start looking at
being open to because some of those
settlements are going to have to be
dismantled if there's gonna be a serious
peace deal I would start you know maybe
having some of those conversations but
the thing is it all seems so pie in the
sky when it's Netanyahu and Hamas mmm
yeah I go you're saying so just be kind
of a try to lower tensions where it
could be the only reason it really
became an issue for me is that like I
volunteered for about two months last
year with the ACLU and these kind of
free speech issues were coming up but
when I was there there was never
anything as huge as the federal
contracts I don't have a whatever I
forgive it was called up Marco Rubio sr1
okay yeah let's not go into that let's
well that's a whole different topic
listen I'm gonna let you go that that's
another topic I don't have time for it
today but I appreciate the phone call
and on that note I am wrapping I've got
a whole bunch of other stuff to do and I
got a new show tomorrow to plan for so
thanks to everybody who joined me thanks
for the super chats the new patrons the
channel members as well as the new
website members thanks to everybody
another stream very soon